bonsoir et bienvenue nous sommes en
direct et ça vous regarde et je suis
ravie de vous retrouver au sommaire ce
soir la clarification d'Emmanuel Macron
sur les retraites le chef de l'État a
précisé sa position hier soir sur France
2 là je légale de départ sera
progressivement reculée à 65 ans à
l'horizon 2031 la porte reste ouverte à
la négociation à 64 ans sous conditions
on y reviendra mais au-delà à quoi bon
travailler plus longtemps si près d'un
seniors sur deux est au chômage comment
faire revenir les plus de 50 ans dans
les entreprises c'est notre grand débat
ce soir notre grand témoin prend la
plume pour la première fois pour lever
le voile sur une histoire familiale
sidérante elle a voulu comprendre
comment dans la Roumanie des années 50
les Juifs ont pu être vendus contre du
bétail en quête historique et intime sa
mère sa tante ses grands-parents son
arrière-grand-mère aussi figuré sur la
liste de ses exportés publiés chez
Flammarion Sonia de Villers journaliste
à France Inter est avec nous ce soir
enfin
trois parties pris ce soir l'histoire du
jour à l'assemblée de Jean-Rémy Baudot
la motion de la censure de la nupette
a-t-elle été modifiée pour attirer les
voix du rassemblement national la mise
en garde du philosophe Pierre-Henri
tavoyau sur des dangers d'une vie
politique trop judiciaire après la mise
en examen Daniel et puis le regard sur
la guerre de vincent Hugeux ce soir
Russie
Ukraine Dieu enroulé de force voilà pour
le manifeste
[Musique]
64 ou 65 ans on connaît désormais la
couleur Emmanuel Macron a dissipé les
doutes pour ceux qui en avaient encore
il va falloir travailler plus longtemps
mais encore faut-il pouvoir le faire la
France est parmi les champions du
chômage des seniors en Europe bonsoir
Marc Ferracci bonsoir et bienvenue sur
ce plateau député renaissance des
Français établis en Suisse ancien
rapporteur de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage ça peut avoir un lien avec la
question du chômage des seniors et vous
venez d'être nommé au Conseil
d'orientation des retraites j'ai appris
que des parlementaires c'est la loi
siégés au corps bonsoir Adrien Clouet et
merci d'être là député la France
insoumise de Haute-Garonne membre de la
commission des des affaires sociales qui
va évidemment plancher sur cette réforme
des retraites à venir bonsoir Franck
Morel bienvenue vous êtes avocat expert
à l'Institut Montaigne qui vient de
publier vendredi dernier un rapport
proposition à l'appui sur le travail des
seniors comment faire en sorte que le
taux d'emploi augmente vous avez été
conseillé social d'Édouard Philippe de
Xavier Bertrand et d'Eric verte le
sociologue Serge Guérin sociologue du
travail va nous rejoindre dans quelques
petits instants le temps pour Stéphane
d'accord qui de nous planter le décor si
j'ai bien compris travailler plus
longtemps oui mais autant pouvoir
vraiment le faire le billet de Blacko
tout de suite on y va
[Musique]
on sort Stéphane
bonsoir messieurs si j'ai bien compris
ce soir alors si j'ai bien compris
Myriam le principal argument contre la
retraite à 65 ou même à 64 ans ce sont
les conséquences que ça pourrait avoir
sur les seniors c'est à dire selon
l'Insee les Français de plus de 55 ans
ouf j'en ai 54 je vous montre malgré
tout
ça ça montre l'évolution du taux
d'emploi et 50 dernières années donc
c'était par tranche d'âge en haut c'est
les moins de 50 ans on va dire qu'il
voyait aujourd'hui il y a 80% des moins
de 50 ans que un boulot 55 59 ça baisse
un peu 73 mais là où ça décroche
vraiment et c'est vraiment là le
problème c'est qu'à partir de 60 ans il
y a plus que 30% des Français qui ont
encore un emploi un peu plus d'où la
question que vous avez déjà posée à quel
j'ajouterai un petit supplément c'est
demander à des gens qui n'ont plus de
boulot de travail plus longtemps est-ce
que ça ne serait pas un peu disons-le un
peu hypocrite on écoute
franchement ce serait assez hypocrite de
décaler l'âge légal je veux dire quand
aujourd'hui on est peu qualifié quand on
vit dans une région qui est en
difficulté industrielle quand on est
soi-même en difficulté qu'on a une
carrière fracturée bon courage déjà pour
arriver à 62 ans c'est ça la réalité de
notre pays alors on va dire NON NON faut
maintenant aller à 64 ans vous savez
déjà plus comment faire après 55 ans les
gens vous disent les emplois c'est plus
bon pour vous c'est ça la réalité c'est
le combat qu'on mène on doit d'abord
gagner ce combat avant d'aller expliquer
aux gens mais bons amis travailler plus
longtemps
et ça fait mal le placard c'était avant
avril 2019 ne croyez pas que le
président se contredise comme ça tout va
l'époque a changé ça c'est de l'époque
où il veut faire une grande réforme des
retraites fini les 42 régimes régime
unique universel quelque chose de
marquant et finalement pour ce second
mandat et ben il va peut-être se
contenter d'une petite réforme des
retraites avec juste augmentation soit
de l'âge de départ soit de la durée de
cotisation pour remplir les caisses plus
modestement
seront forcément les perdants cette
réforme alors pas du tout en tout cas
c'est ce qu'a dit le il a voulu nous
convaincre que si on voulait régler le
problème des seniors et je crois que
c'est ce qu'on veut tous faire ce soir
et ben la meilleure solution c'est de
reculer l'âge de la retraite et vous
savez pourquoi non ça c'est parce que
c'est mécanique non alors c'est vrai
mais la mécanique elle est animée par
quoi par le cynisme des patrons oui oui
c'est le président qui l'a dit plus
votre âge de départ légal il est tôt
plus les entreprises font des plans pour
vous sortir tôt c'est c'est un cynisme
complet c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
vous avez certaines fédérations
patronales qui sont pas pour qu'on fasse
une réforme des retraites parce qu'elle
préfère dire aux gens à 55 ans on a plus
besoin de vous parce que vous êtes trop
chers
a dit qu'il était pour l'allongement de
départ
à la retraite mais ça pose une question
parce que si on recule l'âge de départ à
65 ans il faudrait quand même que les
entreprises gardent les salariés jusqu'à
65 ans évidemment là on part à 32 on
regarde les gens à 60 si on met l'âge à
65 ans et qu'on dérive à 63 il reste
toujours deux ans sans emploi chez
Claire ou c'est pas clair sinon il y a
Laurent Berger qui vous l'explique et
voilà bref que pensent les patrons selon
lui quand on leur dit mais écoutez vous
êtes pas cohérent et je l'ai fait vous
n'êtes pas cohérent ils disent oui mais
là où on les fait partir à 58 ans
peut-être qu'on les fera partir qu'à 61
ans si c'est reporté à 65 ans enfin
c'est de l'hypocrisie collective alors
quelle solution comment on arrive à
augmenter le taux d'emploi des seniors
tout le monde connaît le principe il y a
deux méthodes celle de la carotte et
celle du bâton merci donc on va
commencer par la carotte incitation et
si on voulait inciter les entrepreneurs
employer des décennies en frappe comment
on pourrait les exonérer de cotisations
quand ils ont pas des seigneurs sales
les patrons ah ouais adore les cadeaux
et les filles pas forcément mais par
exemple le ministre propose d'autres
solutions là ça serait pour inciter les
les employés eux-mêmes il dit on
pourrait pour inciter les seniors à
travailler avec un salaire moindre bah
cumuler ça avec un peu
d'être un peu moins bien que le poste
précédent mais compensation d'État c'est
ça oui et le bateau je croyais qu'on
allait oublier le bâton mais non
n'oublions pas le bâton c'est souvent
très efficace je sais pas si vous
connaissez l'index de l'égalité
professionnelle c'est une manière un
dispositif qui permet de sanctionner les
entreprises les entreprises qui
discriminent les femmes selon certains
sortes de certains nombre de critères
pourquoi on ne le ferait pas pour les
vieux si on punit les entreprises qui
discriminent les femmes pourquoi pas
celle qui discriminent les vieux le
retour de Laurent Berger il faut trouver
un mécanisme qui sur l'emploi des
seniors contraint les entreprises à
garder les seniors à pas les licencier à
pas avoir des plans où on fait supporter
à l'assurance chômage ou à l'invalidité
à la caisse d'invalidité le notre
politique de ressources humaines à
lesquelles à l'égard des seniors et si
ça joue pas le jeu oui il faudra passer
par des mécanismes de contraintes je
vous laisse débattre mais si on règle le
problème de l'emploi des seniors qu'on
la remet tout ce boulot l'augmentation
des cotisations frappe on aura même plus
besoin de reculer l'âge de départ à la
retraite c'est pas une bonne idée
ce papier merci de cette précision merci
Stéphane on va partir du diagnostic
parce que vous connaissez tous bien le
dossier pourquoi la France est si
mauvaise élève en matière d'emploi des
seniors qu'est-ce qui peut l'expliquer
déjà quelle est la principale cause les
entreprises on a compris le mécanisme
lâche lâche leur salarié 55 56 un peu
plus et c'est vraiment un phénomène
massif en France marque comme souvent il
y a pas une cause unique mais la cause
principale si on parle de l'emploi parce
que on a utilisé les termes de taux de
chômage ou taux d'emploi de manière un
peu alternative le taux de chômage des
seniors il est plus faible que la
moyenne nationale quelle que soit la
tranche que vous preniez que vous
preniez les 50 5 60 et 60 64 en revanche
le taux d'emploi lui il est plus faible
tenant plein c'est la proportion des
gens qui travaillent sur la population
en âge de travailler dans cette classe
64 ans et beaucoup et sa chute beaucoup
aux alentours de 33% au-delà de 60 ans
le facteur principal de la du taux
d'emploi je ne parle que du taux
d'emploi des seniors c'est bien l'âge de
départ à la retraite d'ailleurs le
graphique que vous avez montré tout à
l'heure est assez éloquent sur cet
aspect là on a vu que le taux d'emploi
des seniors chutait des 60 ans et plus
chuter notamment en 1980 ou aux
alentours de 1980 quand on a mis la
retraite à 60 ans qu'il remontait
ensuite au moment des réformes qui ont
reculé de nouveau et en particulier la
réforme Fillon l'âge de départ à la
retraite donc c'est le facteur majeur
sur le taux d'emploi est-ce que ça veut
dire d'accord avec l'idée que à 65 ans
on va réussir à augmenter ce taux
d'emploi c'est mécanique les études le
prouvent exactement
ces mécanique mais ça ne signifie pas
qu'il ne faille pas se préoccuper du
maintien de l'emploi qu'il ne faille pas
se préoccuper et bien du retour à
l'emploi et je pense qu'il faut
distinguer ces deux aspects là parce que
quand on parle de d'exonérer les gens de
cotisation sociale ou les employeurs de
cotisations sociales pour qu'ils
conservent les seniors ou pour qu'il
reprenne des seniors qui veut et bien
on ne tient pas forcément compte de
l'autre aspect qui est celui de la
recherche d'emploi des seniors et vous
parlez l'index moi j'aime bien cette
idée d'index restons sur le diagnostic
et on ira sur des solutions dans un
deuxième élément fondamental j'en
termine c'est d'avoir un âge légal qui
remonte et de faire en sorte que les
règles de retraite et les règles de
l'assurance chômage parce que c'est très
important soit bien articulé on va en
reparler Adrien quel est votre
diagnostic est-ce que finalement c'est
cette tâche légale qui permet de donner
de la visibilité et qui permet si on les
reculer à 65 64 ans de faire en sorte
qu'on conserve l'emploi des seigneurs
dans les entreprises là on est en train
d'inverser les priorités politiques la
question pour moi elle est pas de savoir
comment on fait pour que les gens se
sont de 10 ans soient au boulot la
question c'est comment on fait pour qu'à
60 ans ils parte à la retraite et en
fait on est en train d'inverser
totalement beaucoup de débats sur les
retraites et sur la réforme en elle-même
on va en refaire simplement
on peut pas sur un diagnostic sans poser
une question politique il n'y a pas de
diagnostics en dehors d'une question
politique et donc à mon sens on utilise
sur un jeu dupe puisque on a d'un côté
un gouvernement qui nous parle de
rallonger la durée passée en emploi sauf
que tous les ans il y a 700 000 seniors
qui quittent un poste donc ça veut dire
qu'on va garder sur des postes de
travail des gens et on va en garder
700000 par an ça revient à contredire
totalement le programme de création
d'emplois pour les jeunes puisqu'on va
maintenir plus longtemps les gens en
emploi donc on ne va pas libérer des
postes qui pourraient l'être et par
ailleurs au dessus de 60 ans on sait
très bien qu'il y a des conséquences
sanitaires très importantes au maintien
en emploi il y a des gens qui sont plus
souvent malades plus souvent en
invalidité ça a plein de raisons
différentes
de réussir à faire en sorte que on garde
les seigneurs dans l'entreprise
le retour de la retraite à 60 ans mais
non mais attendez la question sanitaire
elle est importante parce qu'on a un
gouvernement qui pas ouvrir des lits
d'hôpitaux comme on devrait les avoir
dans les moments de crise sanitaire qui
sont liés pour le coup à des questions
de pandémie ou à différentes crises et
là on va réouvrir un nouveau chantier de
difficulté sanitaires en maintenant en
emploi ou en mettant en emploi des
millions de personnes dans des
conditions qui détériorent leur santé
alors on va essayer quand même de pas
être je dirais pas forcément dans le
hors sujet mais essayez de regarder la
question de l'emploi des seigneurs et de
la recherche d'emploi bonsoir Serge
Guérin bonsoir on a besoin du regard du
sociologue ce soir du terrain les
chômeurs de plus de 55 ans en France qui
sont-ils donc quel type d'entreprise
est-ce que c'est plus des cadres ou au
contraire des ouvriers du travail
qualifié du travail moins qualifié
qu'est-ce qu'on sait sur cette réalité
là aujourd'hui alors globalement le
problème c'est d'abord c'est celui de
l'âge c'est le problème des
représentations pour les entreprises
mais pas seulement pour la société en
général la représentation est plutôt une
représentation négative alors parfois un
peu sur un côté
ils sont malades ils sont plus fatigués
que les autres ainsi de suite parce que
pas nécessairement vrai d'ailleurs ou
bien ça va être un discours sur par
rapport aux technologies sont pas à
l'aise ainsi de suite et d'ailleurs les
les élections
parce que quand vous avez perdu votre
job et vous en rechercher à 45 ans à 50
ans à 55 ans parfois vous n'êtes pas
trop regardant aussi sur votre salaire
et parfois aussi
vous êtes aussi parfois dans une logique
de se dire j'ai envie de faire autre
chose à l'inseek dirige un master qui
forme les directeurs des établissements
de santé j'ai 20% 25% de candidats qui
ont 45 50 ans 55 ans voire plus et eux
leur logique c'est j'ai envie de faire
un autre métier un métier où il y a plus
de sens et eux bah souvent ils disent je
suis prêt à gagner moins parce que ce
qui m'intéresse c'est le sens donc ça
dépend aussi de votre parcours de vie si
je peux aller les enfants c'est réglé si
vous avez remboursé vous emprunts ainsi
de suite donc ça dépend aussi des
situations
alors comme souvent la première question
c'est celle de la formation
moins vous avez diplôme moins bien vous
êtes formés plus c'est difficile de
rester en emploi quel que soit l'âge et
on avance en âge encore plus sachant que
par ailleurs on a la très mauvaise idée
après 45 ans de beaucoup moins former
les gens du coup après 45 ans ça divise
par 4 la formation 45 parce qu'on dit 55
65 vous vous dites attention ça décroche
des 45 ans je suis désolé pour les gens
qui ont 44 ans et demi qui sont en train
de nous écouter mais à 45 ans alors ça a
été inventé aussi à avec avec Laurent
Wauquiez en 2010 c'était l'entretien de
mi carrière il y en a certains qui sont
dit ouh là là ça sent le
elles sont mauvais pour moi
dans l'entreprise dès 45 ans à son de
gens qui considèrent pas ça y est c'est
réglé et donc du coup c'est si je ne
suis pas arrivé à telle ou tel niveau je
vais avoir du mal c'est-à-dire que on
fait un procès en vieillissement précoce
alors même qu'on vit de plus en plus
longtemps on le fait de plus en plus tôt
donc là il y a quelque chose d'un peu
qui fonctionne pas franchement elle
votre regard à l'Institut Montaigne sur
le diagnostic on va avoir un petit sujet
pour les entendre aussi c'est seniors
qui galèrent mais pourquoi on est si
mauvais en matière d'emploi des choses
quand même c'est que quand on regarde ce
qui s'est passé au cours des 20
dernières années on peut constater que
le taux d'emploi des seniors sur la
tranche 55 65 ans il a pris 20 points de
plus donc évidemment la question des
différentes réformes qui ont pu être
prises et notamment celle de 2010 par
exemple donc sur le rôle effectivement
c'est l'effet mécanique qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure on jouait sur cette
Télévation progressive du taux d'emploi
des séances voilà effectivement on peut
pas se satisfaire de ces chiffres même
s'ils sont dans une dynamique positive
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
qu'effectivement si on regarde la
tranche au-delà de 60 ans là pour le
coup on est 12 à 13 points derrière la
moyenne européenne il y a une situation
qui est perfectible qui peut être
grandement améliorée
il faut quand même figurer les choses
c'est beaucoup et puis il y a ce monde
et puis la seconde raison pour laquelle
on ne peut pas s'en satisfaire c'est que
si on veut que la réforme des retraites
nous sommes à l'orée d'une réforme des
retraites soit un plein succès et ben il
faut évidemment mettre le paquet sur
l'emploi seniors et c'est pour ça que
moi je plaide et c'est ce que j'ai fait
à travers le rapport qui vient de sortir
pour une réforme en matière d'emplois
des seniors qui agit sur tous les
leviers quel est le diagnostic qu'on
peut faire sur les politiques publiques
qui ont été menées depuis une vingtaine
d'années en matière d'employés c'est que
le musée malheureusement des dispositifs
qui ont échoué et bien fournis on a
quantité d'exemples de dispositifs qui
ont été tentés qui n'ont pas marché
de génération qui a été un flop total la
contribution de la lande qui a été un
échec retentissant et malheureusement le
CDD seniors qui date pourtant 2006 qui
n'a pas pris donc voilà trois exemples
d'outils politiques publiques on va pas
parler des outils et des dispositifs qui
n'ont pas marché on va se projeter sur
vos propositions je vous propose de les
entendre hein ces seigneurs au chômage
qui n'en peuvent plus de multiplier les
guichets les CV paroles de plus de 50
ans restez sur le carreau on voit cela
avec Maël Morin
du jour au lendemain avec l'arrivée du
covid tout s'est arrêté pour Tania à 59
ans cette professeur d'anglais à
l'université de la Sorbonne à Paris
s'est retrouvé sans emploi là j'étais
sur mon cinquième CDD et normalement
j'allais passer en CD et là ils ont
supprimé tous les postes en CDD donc je
me suis trouvé en chemin une situation
qui dure depuis plus d'un an en dépit de
nombreux entretiens d'embauche aucun
employeur ne s'est montré intéressé par
son profil senior c'est déprimant
frustrant moi je suis voilà au chômage
j'ai perdu beaucoup d'argent et aussi je
trouve que tu l'expérience les gens ça
ne se connaissent pas du tout c'est moi
mon CV il est super longue avec plein
d'expériences je trouve que je peux être
très enrichissant pour une fac ou
université ou une sorte de formation et
rien ne dit qu'elle décrochera un emploi
d'ici trois ans elle aura 62 ans l'âge
de la retraite dans ces conditions
reculer l'âge légal de départ à 64 voir
65 ans lui paraît surréaliste
travailler jusqu'à 65 ans comme déjà à
45 on ne veut plus on est trop vieille
on est trop cher voilà la retraite à 64
ou 65 ans on en veut pas non plus chez
les actifs en fin de carrière dans cette
boucherie Christian a commencé à
travailler à 14 ans pas question de
faire une année de plus moi j'ai mon
taux plein dans un an vu mon état de
santé je peux pas je suis asthmatique je
vous ai dit je suis asthmatique et j'ai
fait déjà la factus donc moi je peux pas
faire 5 ans ou si en plus quand vous
voyez que ça fait 44 ans que vous
travaillez et on vous vous dites bon
dans cinq ans c'est bon je suis à la
retraite et que là on vous annonce ah
bah non finalement va vous prolonger de
5 ans mais en quelle honneur donc je
vais profiter de mes petits-enfants
quand je serai en déambulateur maison de
retraite pour être fixé il faudra
attendre l'examen de la réforme par le
Parlement prévu cet hiver
Marc Ferracci il y a une réforme des
retraites qui est très compliquée à
faire passer ici avec cette nouvelle
donne politique il y aura forcément dans
ce texte un volet emploi des seniors il
y aura forcément un volant et plus
largement il y aura un volet qui mettra
en place les mesures que suggère le
témoignage et les témoignages que vous
venez de montrer des mesures qui
prendront en compte les questions de
pénibilité les questions de carrière
longue c'est à dire ces personnes qui
ont commencé à travailler avant 20 ans
et qui ont tout leur trimestres alors
que l'âge légal n'est pas encore arrivé
les questions d'emplois et je veux
m'arrêter sur le témoignage de cette
professeur d'anglais on évoquait tout à
l'heure la question d'un index senior
moi je trouve que c'est un outil
intéressant à deux titres d'abord parce
que c'est un outil vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure qui peut avoir comme vertu de
responsabiliser les employeurs et on
sait que l'index égalité homme-femme
commence à produire des effets le taux
d'emploi de Seigneur dans la boîte je
pense qu'il faut être simple il faut pas
faire des choses trop compliquées
peut-être d'ailleurs que l'index égalité
pro homme femme n'est pas le modèle à
suivre il faut déjà une la formation
claire sur est-ce que la boîte embauche
des seniors éventuellement on la
comparant aux entreprises de son secteur
parce que évidemment toutes les
activités n'ont pas vocation à faire
venir des gens d'un certain âge ça c'est
une information très importante d'une
part pour responsabiliser les employeurs
et d'autre part c'est exactement
l'exemple que vous avez vu pour aider
les gens dans leur recherche d'emploi
parce que un élément de démobilisation
qui fait qu'on reste parfois très
longtemps au chômage c'est quand on
envoie des dizaines et des centaines de
CV à des entreprises qui de toute façon
implicitement parce qu'elles n'ont pas
le droit de faire explicitement ça ce
serait discriminatoire mais
implicitement ont décidé qu'elle
n'emplerait pas des seniors le fait de
dire regardez dans votre secteur dans
votre société il y a des éléments
ça c'est le premier point dire aux entre
dire aux personnes qui cherchent au-delà
de 50 ou 55 ans cible les 10 ou 15
entreprises de ton secteur qui recrutent
des seniors qui font cette démarche ça
aide à la recherche d'emploi et c'est
très important parce que la recherche
d'emploi est souvent très efficace
il est mal question ouverte je pense que
la discussion est en train d'avoir lieu
entre le mystes du travail et les
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre des
concertations sur la réforme et je pense
que les deux options toutes les options
doivent être sur la table et l'autre
élément j'en termine qui est très
important dans cette logique là c'est
effectivement que quand vous arrivez
autre chômage à 50 ou 55 ans souvent
vous êtes en haut des grilles salariales
vous avez un bon niveau de vie vous avez
un appartement à payer vous avez les
études de vos enfants et les offres qui
vous sont faites en tant que demandeur
d'emploi sont souvent assortis d'une
baisse d'une décote salariale et donc il
faut compenser cette organisation ça ça
peut être la solution la solution de
Olivier du socle moi j'aurai une
préférence pour une solution qui
consisterait à dire dès que vous
reprenez un job et plutôt vous reprenez
un job plutôt vous allez avoir une prime
importante de reprise d'emploi parce que
il faut encore avoir en tête cette idée
que c'est très tôt qu'il faut agir quand
on reste 6 mois ou un an au chômage
au-delà de 55 ans ça devient très
compliqué parce que vous envoyez un
signal aux employeurs qui est lui-même
négatif deux idées un index pourquoi pas
avec sanction à l'appui favorable ou pas
que vous voulez aller plus loin avec des
quotas des bas existe de Seigneur dans
l'entreprise et puis cette idée au fond
que l'État pourrait presque dire
subventionne en partie de l'emploi des
seigneurs dans l'entreprise
c'est-à-dire nous donc on va se
retrouver
en l'occurrence dans les propositions
qu'on a expliqué donc les cotisants les
cotisants donc nous donc on a une
situation chômage bah vous avez la CSG
et ne part pas trop mal c'est pas trop
mal et les salaires qu'on reçoit donc
dans les deux cas effectivement on a de
l'argent public qui serait pris pour
venir subventionner des créations
d'emplois il me semble que la
responsabilité de l'emploi elle doit pas
incomber spécifiquement à l'état et je
m'étonne d'ailleurs que ce soit la ligne
qui est défendue aujourd'hui mais plutôt
aux entreprises vous avez choisi de
rebondir sur le témoignage de la
professeur qui était extrêmement
intéressant je voudrais moins attirer
l'attention sur celui du boucher puisque
quelle est la différence finalement dans
ce pays entre avoir 60 ans et avoir 65
ans la différence entre les deux c'est
30 000 morts tous les ans donc ça
signifie que dès lors que vous repoussez
là je départ à la retraite vous créez
une situation dans laquelle des
centaines de milliers de gens décéderont
avant d'avoir vécu une linges à la
retraite dans notre pays il faut s'en
féliciter
encore que la courbe actuellement elle
est plate mais vous avez dans tous les
cas aujourd'hui un décalage c'est à dire
tout choix qui consiste à repousser là
je démarre à la retraite signifie que
des gens mourront avant d'y partir c'est
mathématiques et à partir de là à partir
de là quelle est la question politique
vous les questions sur les enfin en tout
cas les démarches les propositions sur
lesquelles vous m'interrogez consiste à
maintenir plus longtemps les seniors en
emploi et comme vous voulez absolument
revenir 60 ans à partir du moment où je
suis favorable effectivement
autoriser le départ à la retraite à
l'âge de 60 ans il me semble que les
pistes intéressantes c'est de savoir sur
quel revenu on élargit les cotisations
on rappellera que par exemple la prime
Macron qui a été votée au mois de
juillet constitue un type de revenu qui
ne contribue pas à l'assurance
vieillesse et donc ne contribue pas au
droit de départ et par exemple on
pourrait aussi mettre sur la table
l'idée de élever le niveau de revenus à
partir duquel on arrête de cotiser on
arrête presque totalement de cotiser
l'assurance vieillesse puisque
aujourd'hui au-delà de 3400 euros de
salaire par mois vous cessez quasiment
il reste une petite part mais vous
contribuez presque plus à l'assurance
vieillesse on comprend en tout cas côté
députés là il y aura une ligne rouge
enfin il y aura pas d'accord sur cette
réforme personne n'est surpris y compris
ce qui nous regarde j'en suis j'en suis
convaincu Serge Guérin quelle solution
au fond est-ce que ça peut pas venir du
terrain est-ce que ça peut pas venir
d'une consultation citoyenne des
premiers intéressés tous les rapports
sont sont sur la table qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent plus d'accompagnement de la
formation pour changer et éventuellement
de de travail de vocation il y a
énormément de choses en effet c'est pas
une réponse qui suffira et en effet à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu une réponse à
jamais bien marché il y a eu des
campagnes publicitaires assez ridicule
sur l'emploi des seniors par exemple
voilà il y a eu plein de choses le
premier élément c'est de se rappeler
aussi que un senior égale pas un autre
senior c'est pas parce que vous avez 57
ans vous ressemblez à quelqu'un d'autre
de 57 ans si vous êtes un ouvrier
spécialisé votre vie et pas la même une
solution
ça c'est la première élément deuxième
élément il y a des solutions de fait
sociaux c'est-à-dire le problème premier
à mon sens c'est les représentations les
représentations restent très négatives
sur l'âge en T50 ans à 55 ans à 60 ans
il y a quand même ça qui reste de
manière très forte ah ça c'est compliqué
ça fait un moment qu'on essaye et
globalement c'est pas une grande
réussite si ce n'est que il y a une
réalité toute bête c'est que la société
vieillit c'est une réalité on la
pyramide démographique l'augmentation de
la population elle va se faire par le
haut c'est pas par des enfants les les
millions qui va y avoir de gens en plus
ça sera des gens de plus de 60 ans donc
c'est là où ça se passe donc ici arrivé
à faire comprendre ça ça c'est la
première chose deuxième élément c'est
accompagner les personnes alors
accompagner les dirigeants les
ressources humaines ainsi de suite pour
qu'elles conserve les salariés qui ont
l'âge en leur disant vous rendez pas
service vous vous faites pas ça par
morale vous faites ça parce que vous y
avez intérêt un salarié senior c'est un
salarié
inviter le patron des DRH mais
malheureusement il pouvait pas être
présent c'est l'expérience des personnes
avec les étudiants je fais un test je
dis dessine-moi un seniors ça se termine
avec une canne
55 ans
d'expérimenté pour être expérimenté
généralement faut être seniors et là
d'un seul coup il y a autre chose tiens
valoriser l'expérience je crois qu'il y
a quelque chose très fort autour de ça
et l'autre élément c'est réfléchir à des
innovations ou à Dominique Taddeï dans
les années 80 il parlait déjà de
retraite à la carte qu'on parte
progressivement à la retraite peut-être
à 64 ans trois semaines sur quatre et
puis ensuite deux semaines sur quatre
ainsi de suite il y a les doucement et
pas nécessairement un coup près vous
travaillez et du jour au travail
peut-être une décision d'allonger les
trimestres de cotisations les syndicats
vont devoir se positionner là-dessus
Franck Morel l'index l'Institut
Montaigne il favorable moi je suis
favorable à l'index parce
qu'effectivement je cons reste un outil
qui est à la fois fixe un objectif de
résultat et qui est assez souple et qui
comme l'a dit marcarachi plutôt fait ses
preuves en matière d'égalité homme-femme
avec une variété de possibilités
sanction fait partie des possibilités le
principe de l'index me paraît
intéressant en revanche il y a un point
que je voudrais souligner avec beaucoup
de force c'est que il serait 20 de ne se
limiter qu'à l'index il faut évidemment
je le redis agir sur tous les leviers
agir sur tous les leviers ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire agir sur l'écosystème
assurance chômage marque ferrachi a
donné un exemple je vais en donner un
autre à travers ce que j'appelle le
système de préretraite
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'elle est assouplie pour les
seniors ou pas alors je vais venir
l'écosystème d'assurance chômage c'est
le fait qu'il existe un certain nombre
de dispositifs en matière
d'indemnisation chômage des seniors qui
peuvent être des véritables appels d'air
à des ruptures de contrat de travail
vous avez un pic de rupture des contrats
de travail à 59 ans aujourd'hui trois
ans avant l'âge légal d'ouverture à la
retraite de départ à la retraite il
était en 2007 avant la réforme de 2010 à
57 ans c'est-à-dire là aussi pile trois
ans avant l'âge légal de l'époque
d'air des mécanismes d'indemnisation en
matière d'assurance chômage c'est un
premier point mais là aussi il serait 20
de se limiter seulement à ce sujet il
faut aussi agir sur le système de
retraite en tant que tel vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure le cumul emploi retraite
effectivement faut favoriser le cube
l'emploi retraite il y avait des
propositions sur la surcotte en matière
de retraite et puis il faut agir
également sur la gestion des fins de
carrière moi je propose un mécanisme de
gestion des fins de carrière qui permet
de signer une convention de faire un
deal avec le Seigneur en fin de carrière
en échangeant maintien en emploi assuré
pour cette personne pendant un certain
nombre d'années contre un job qui sera
différent du job qui était tenu par
l'intéressé soit parce qu'il est à temps
partiel donc moins bien payé soit parce
qu'il est sur une autre fonction et avec
cotisation retraite sur l'ancien salaire
et versement en avance de phase de
l'indemnité de licenciement et puis
global il faut avoir un système de
cotisation sociale qui favorise l'emploi
de ceux dans le taux d'emploi est plus
faible on a deux générations donc en
gros vous baissez les
cotisationsnel c'est de faire en sorte
que au prix d'un plus un sur la tranche
d'âge 35 ans et bien on puisse baisser
de deux points et demi les taux de
cotisations patronales sur les plus
jeunes et sur les plus âgés vous faites
payer la classe moyenne qui travaille en
termes d'âge j'entends pas pour
diminuer le coût du travail de l'emploi
des seniors et des plus jeunes bonne
idée ou pas sur cette dernière idée je
vais commencer par par me fâcher avec
avec mon collègue France Morel parce que
c'est parmi les idées qui sont dans le
rapport de l'Institut Montaigne celle
que je ne soutiens pas pour une raison
simple c'est que les allégements de
cotisation sociale il doit être motivé
par le rapport entre le coût du travail
et la productivité ça a été dit il y a
aucune preuve que la productivité des
seniors baisse et que donc il est
légitime de baisser le coût du travail
pour les seniors c'est là qu'il faut
changer les mentalités parce que les
entreprises pensent pas du tout ça et
cette et cette proposition aboutirait au
contraire à augmenter le coût du travail
de 1 point si j'ai bien compris sur une
classe d'âge dont la productivité
peut-être faible ça signifie
concrètement vous allez détruire de
l'emploi entre 25 et 49
j'en suis désolé mais cette proposition
je ne la retiens pas en revanche toutes
les autres propositions et en
particulier les autres propositions les
autres propositions qui lisent à
individualiser les réponses et en
particulier développer ainsi un
dispositif de cumulant retraite qui soit
plus attractif je souscris beaucoup à ce
qui était dit par Monsieur Guérin l'idée
que il faut pouvoir partir à la retraite
de manière beaucoup plus progressive
aujourd'hui vous avez un dispositif de
cumul qui ne permet pas l'acquisition
des droits à la retraite quand vous
cumulez votre retraite avec votre
salaire et c'est pas très attractif il
faut le renforcer le rendre plus
généreux de la même manière qu'il faut
rendre plus généreux le dispositif
carrière longue précisément pour tenir
compte de ces gens qui ont travaillé
plus tôt et enfin je souscris également
très fortement et ce qui a été dit sur
la nécessité d'aménager les fins de
carrière de manière négocier c'est à
dire en tenant compte des contraintes de
l'entreprise et des contraintes de la
personne juste un dernier point il y a
les représentations il y a aussi quelque
chose de plus mécanique et de plus
déterministe c'est que les seniors
coûtent cher s'il y a des plantes départ
volontaires ou des ruptures
conventionnelles individuelles ou
collectives massif pour les seniors
c'est pas ce qu'effectivement il y a une
filière d'indemnisation chômage qui dure
3 ans et franchement elle l'a très bien
dit 8 ans parfois 8 ans
par cette question de l'assurance
chômage parce que les réformes retraites
et assurance chômage sont évidemment
liées vu qu'il y en avait été le
rapporteur assoupli ou pas pour la
catégorie spécifique des seniors au
chômage cette réforme moi je pense que
sur les mêmes je pense qu'on gagnerait
collectivement à traiter les deux sujets
de concert c'est à dire avoir une
cohérence entre ce qui est fait en
termes de retraite et ce qui est fait en
termes d'assurance chômage je vais pas
je vais pas dans un contexte où il y a
de l'emploi vous êtes à 65 enfin 60 ans
au chômage aujourd'hui vous avez la
réforme qui fait moi longtemps les
allocations ça vous concerné si c'est ça
qui est choisi qui est retenu par le
gouvernement effectivement mais
j'insiste sur ce point
d'exception pour les pour les seniors au
chômage non bénéficier aujourd'hui vous
avez déjà une exception c'est les 36
mois alors que le droit commun c'est 24
je pense que il faut que le principe de
la modulation des règles en fonction de
la conjoncture s'applique à tout le
monde voilà bon je vous donne le mot de
la fin Adrien close sur ce dossier là la
gauche radicale ne sera pas ne sera pas
au rendez-vous
on est évidemment favorable à au droit
de partir à la retraite à l'âge de 60
ans d'avoir une animation chômage qui
couvre les personnes jusqu'à leur départ
en retraite dans le cas où elle perdrait
leur emploi un certain âge et je
conclurai en rappelant que on parle
beaucoup d'emplois mais il faut se
souvenir beaucoup de retraités
travaillent en fait hors emploi les
associations elles sont avant tout
composées de personnes qui sont en
retraite 46% retraités sont actifs dans
une association donc dès lors que vous
repoussez là je départ à la retraite les
premières victimes c'est la ligne droite
de l'homme la ligue de protection des
oiseaux et l'association en bas de chez
vous qui fait du l'humanitaire et du
karité un débat de fond un philosophique
même en perspective dans l'hémicycle la
réforme des retraites on a un petit
calendrier là où les concertations ont
commencé entre le ministère les
partenaires sociaux et normalement il y
a un projet de loi qui doit arriver au
Parlement tout début d'année prochaine
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir débattu sur
ce plateau on va accueillir à présent
notre grand témoin les journalistes à
France Inter on la connaît pour ses
interviews mordantes des acteurs de la
vie des médias notamment elle signe chez
Flammarion un premier récit littéraire
vous allez voir c'est passionnants ça
s'appelle les exportés ou l'histoire
effarante d'un trafic de juifs contre du
bétail dans la Roumanie de la fin des
années 50 en quête historique en cas de
familiale aussi sur des déchirures de
l'exil forcé on accueille Sonia
Devillers juste après l'invitation
signée ce soir Marco poli
si on vous invite Sonia de Villers c'est
pour une histoire sidérante encore
méconnue et sans image Roumanie fin des
années 50 le régime communiste veut
moderniser son agriculture les caisses
sont vides alors le pays monnaie ses
Juifs avec la complicité d'un passeur un
certain Henry acober avec l'argent des
familles juives il organise leur
transfert à l'étranger un afériste sans
scrupule qui offre un retour des
machines et du bétail à l'État romain un
troc à peine croyable il a fallu
attendre 1989 la chute du mur de Berlin
puis la chute du régime communiste en
Roumanie pour que s’ouvre les archives
pour que les historiens s'en emparent
pour que des listes soient publiées et
que sur ces listes de familles exportées
de famille vendues à l'étranger contre
du bétail figure le nom de mes
grands-parents Sonia Devillers vous êtes
journaliste côté voie vous êtes une
figure de la radio bien connu des
auditeurs de France Inter côté images
vous animez une nouvelle émission
quotidienne sur Arte mais ce soir de
vous nous retenons votre côté plume les
exporter c'est votre premier livre un
récit intime une enquête journaliste sur
votre famille maternelle juive vendu par
le régime roumain en 1961 une famille
tombait en dise grâce au sein du parti
communiste car à l'époque en Roumanie
impossible d'être communiste et juifs
c'est la vérité sur le départ de mon
arrière-grand-mère de mes grands-parents
de ma mère elle avait 14 ans et de ma
tante eux-mêmes n'ont jamais su pourquoi
et comment ils ont été autorisés à
quitter la Roumanie en 1961 c'était un
état totalitaire fermé à double tour nul
ne pouvait en franchir les frontières et
pourtant votre famille franchira bel et
bien le rideau de fer il débarqueront à
Paris Gare de l'Est le 19 décembre 19 61
un voyage terrorisant signé le passeur
enriakober 12000 dollars contre des
papiers c'est ce qu'il obtiendra de vos
grands-parents s'il n'avait pas obtenu
de papier s'il n'avait pas grâce à ce
passeur réussi à franchir la frontière
ils auraient probablement terminé en
prison à son arrivée au pouvoir le
dictateur communiste tchao arrêtera ce
trafic avant de le relancer face aux
besoins d'argent du régime il dira que
les Juifs et le pétrole étaient les
meilleurs produits d'exportation de la
Roumanie
[Musique]
bonsoir Sonia de Villers bonsoir et
merci beaucoup d'être là alors c'est une
longue enquête sur cette Roumanie des
années 50 le pays de toute votre famille
maternelle c'est une enquête aussi sur
les silences de cette famille une part
d'amnésie volontaire on va en parler sur
ces grands-parents Harry et Gabriel
hagridberg devenu on en parlera de la de
les à nous j'ai grandi avec un trou au
milieu de l'Europe c'est ce que vous
écrivez au début du livre comment vous
avez décidé un jour de dire ça suffit je
veux remplir je veux combler ce trou
qu'est-ce qui a été le déclic alors le
déclic c'est de découvrir les listes les
listes de ce pasteur qui était chargé
donc de d'exporter des Juifs et
d'importer du bétail en Roumanie il faut
savoir que
ce pays totalitaire avait une
administration obsessionnelle et
tatillonne et que tout a été consigné de
ce commerce de Juifs donc on a des
registres du commerce on a des
inventaires on a des listes il y a 20
000 pages d'archives il se trouve qu'il
y a un grand historien d'origine
roumaine qui travaillait à Washington au
Mémorial de la Shoah qui a exhumé ses
20000 pages d'archives qui en a publié
une partie et quand j'ai découvert le
nom de mes grands-parents sur ces
archives historiques ça a été vraiment
une sorte de choc une sorte de vertige
et et voilà et le déclencheur mais
qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à la liste il
y avait une questionnement familial il y
avait depuis longtemps cette envie vous
avez fait plusieurs voyages en Roumanie
j'ai fait plusieurs voyages en Roumanie
mais la question ne s'était jamais posée
avant la publication de la liste jamais
posé c'est-à-dire que mes grands-parents
connaissaient le nom du Passeur ils
n'ont jamais imaginé de l'idée qu'il
puisse y avoir un troc entre du beurre
ce passeur le concert c'est un
personnage extrêmement complexe il est
installé à Londres c'est un commerçant
prospère c'est quelqu'un qui a voyagé
dans le monde entier notamment dans les
pays producteurs de bétail en Argentine
au Brésil mais notamment les pays du
Nord le Danemark qui possède ces fameux
port Landrais ce que toute l'Europe veut
se procurer à la fin des années 50 et au
début des années 60 il faut bien savoir
qu'il y a pas que la Roumanie qui
cherche à moderniser son agriculture et
intensifier son élevage dans ses années
là c'est exactement la même chose en
Bretagne par exemple c'est le moment où
on crée des élevages intensifs de porc
mais pour ça il faut avoir les bonnes
espèces les bonnes races porcines et
donc Yako beurre non seulement c'est un
maquignon c'est quelqu'un qui fait de
l'import-export c'est un intermédiaire
spécialiste du marché du bétail
qui entrent et qui sort qui qui franchit
le rideau de fer en continu qui entre et
qui sort en Roumanie et qui a un immense
carnet d'adresses en Roumanie c'est
quelqu'un qui est en cheville avec tous
les étages de la police politique qu'on
appelle la sécurité à l'époque et avec
tous les étages du Parti communiste
est-ce que c'est un ou est-ce que
c'est plus compliqué que ça il faut dire
qu'il est Juifs lui-même alors il faut
dire qu'il est juif lui-même il est
probablement d'un cynisme immense il y a
un moment dans le livre où je me pose la
question est-ce qu'on doit le le
comparer à Oscar Schindler qui était
injuste
Oscar Schindler il a donné jusqu'à son
dernier bouton pour sauver 1200 Juifs de
la déportation
grâce à eux au début
probablement que il y a Cober et
quelqu'un qui a fait des marges toutes
sa vie c'est d'ailleurs la seule
inconnue de cette histoire on ne sait
pas à quel point il s'est enrichissé
c'est le c'est la seule chose qui
échappe aux archives on sait pas combien
il s'est mis dans la poche mais quand le
quand les services secrets israéliens se
sont intéressés à ce drôle de type il le
traite avec un mépris immense pour eux
c'est un signe qui se fait un juif qui
se fait de l'argent sur le dos des Juifs
et pourtant c'est quelqu'un qui sait
faire qui a un savoir-faire logistique
qui sait faire sortir des êtres humains
d'un pays et qui sait faire rentrer du
bétail il est précieux pour ça quand
votre famille arrive dans les années 60
au début des années 60 à Paris ils
ignorent complètement tout ça c'est ça
qui est fou comment elle est née cette
idée folle complètement folle le troc ce
trafic entre des êtres humains des juifs
contre des cochons contre des pores
c'est en fait l'idée c'est à dire qu'en
réalité il n'y a pas d'idées il n'y a
pas de débat éthique il n'y a pas de
pensée tout ça c'est un impensé
investinée c'est une urgence économique
la Roumanie doit intensifier son élevage
doit moderniser son agriculture les
caisses du régime sont vides la Roumanie
n'a pas les moyens de se procurer des
machines-outils et du bétail il faut
trouver une monnaie d'échange et cette
monnaie d'échange ça va être tout
simplement une population une population
que dans le fond le régime communiste ne
considèrera jamais et n'a jamais
considéré comme des citoyens roumains à
part entière donc en réalité c'est du
pragmatisme cette histoire elle
concentre à mon avis le pire du
communisme et le pire du capitalisme
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment l'idée
que tout se vend et tout s'achète y
compris la liberté y compris des êtres
humains y compris des familles entières
ma grand-mère grands-parents parents et
enfants alors vous décrivez très bien le
vertige que vous ressentez quand vous
voyez ce nom sur cette liste de Juifs
faut bien comprendre qu'on est 15 ans
après la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale et la Shoah dans un pays atroce
du point de vue des peaux chrome des
massacres la Roumanie d'abord
c'est ce sont des Juifs alors que ce
judaïsme ne signifie rien absolument
rien pour cette grand-mère
Gabriela expliquez-nous ça ça n'a jamais
intéressé
mais c'est même profondément un rejet il
faut se remettre du point de vue de
cette génération qui n'avait qu'un seul
mot à la bouche c'était la laïcité et
l'assimilation c'était tout sauf des
bigots mais vraiment alors en plus il se
trouve que là il s'agissait
d'intellectuel qui avait une haute
opinion de la culture qui parlait un
français parfait qui parlait l'allemand
mais je jouais piano qui jouait du piano
etc mais d'une grande famille une grande
lignée d'intellectuelle roumain il y
avait même des académiciens dans la
famille etc mais surtout c'est une
génération qui était très peu intéressée
par la chose religieuse et donc c'est
une génération qui part dignité par
fierté à refusé de changer de nom
pendant la guerre incroyable c'est même
incroyable ma grand-mère me dit quand
j'étais petite le seul moment voilà où
elle se serait sentie comment dire
indigne de changer de nom à ce moment-là
où elle s'est sentie fière d'être vu
mais dès que les que les alors il faut
savoir que la Roumanie était l'Allier le
principal allié des nazis en Europe de
l'Est à la fin de la guerre les
communistes arrivent c'est la libération
et sont libérés du jouffagiste c'est à
ce moment là que mes grands-parents
décident de changer non et ils
choisissent un nom dans un roman à la
mode ils choisissent un nom qui les
débarrasse complètement de ce passé juif
de ce fardeau de de cette éternelle
discrimination de cette peur de cette
honte il choisit un nom pour se ré
dans un nouveau monde parce que s'ils ne
sont pas juifs en tant que on vous
assigne une identité ils sont
communistes alors ils sont de
communistes tout court ils y croient
durent comme faire avec oui ils adhèrent
aux partis communistes comme énormément
de Juifs de robes de l'Est à la fin de
la guerre c'est-à-dire c'est pour eux
les libérateurs c'est ce qu'il est
libère du jour fasciste et antisémite
c'est réellement la croyance en
l'avènement du genre humain c'est-à-dire
une forme d'égalité
vraiment la fin des discriminations au
sein de l'humanité ils y croient avec
authenticité et conviction ils adhèrent
d'ailleurs ils vont faire une très belle
carrière au parti communiste une très
belle carrière ma grand-mère deviendra
et musicienne elle deviendra professeur
de musicologie au Conservatoire national
de Bucarest elle sera la directrice
administrative d'un orchestre très
prestigieux mon grand-père va diriger
toutes les industries de la région de
Bucarest en réalité là aussi il y a un
non dit le nom dit c'est l'antisémitisme
séculaire qui en Roumanie qui a été
extrêmement virulent dans
l'entre-deux-guerres extrêmement
virulent et officiel en antisémitisme
d'État pendant la guerre mais qui n'est
absolument pas purgé cette entité qui
les rattrape d'une certaine façon après
la guerre mais dont il parle si peu
pendant la guerre ça c'est très fort
c'est tout le début du livre vous
expliquer qu'il y a une forme de
blackout il y a eu des faits alors que
votre grand-père a fait mourir pris dans
un pogrome en plus un abattoir donc on
pense effectivement à toute l'imaginaire
symbolique que ça renvoie après quand on
connaît l'histoire des exportés pourquoi
pourquoi ce silence sur ce qu'ils ont
traversé un double silence je pense
qu'il y a le silence intime
des Juifs de Roumanie et de beaucoup de
Juifs en Europe de l'Est qui voulaient
en finir avec la tragédie en finir avec
cette histoire en finir avec cette
éternelle différence
et puis il y a le silence politique
c'est à dire que l'arrivée des
communistes au pouvoir signifie une
grande entreprise de falsification de
l'histoire les communistes ne peuvent
pas sont les adversaires historiques des
fascistes et ne peuvent pas assumer le
passé fasciste ne peuvent pas assumer
l'héritage des fascistes donc il y a une
sorte de double silence qui se superpose
et de révisionnisme et de donc il y a un
révisionnisme politique et puis il y a
derrière ça un silence intime la volonté
de regarder devant et d'en finir avec
cette histoire et cette différence des
Juifs de Roumanie cette différence des
Juifs dans un pays antisémite c'est
aussi un livre très intime c'est quelque
chose d'une quête familiale d'un trou à
combler c'est aussi un livre de femme on
sent vraiment qu'à la fois votre mère a
décidé aussi en ne vous transmettant pas
le roumain de vous protéger de vous
protéger ses enfants et que vous d'une
certaine façon vous vous bouclez la
boucle en mettant des mots une écriture
aussi littéraire j'ai le choix de
raconter cette histoire à la première
personne et la raconter à la première
personne dire je c'est trouver ma place
dans cette histoire c'est dire j'en fais
partie même si je suis né de l'autre
côté du de faire je suis la première
année à l'ouest dans un pays libre parce
que quand je suis né évidemment le mur
n'est tombé qu'en 89 et moi je suis en
1975 je suis né de l'autre côté du
rideau de fer je suis la première qui ne
qui ne fuira pas son pays qui ne sera
pas frappé par l'exil dont les enfants
vont parler la même langue que ma langue
maternelle à moi et oui je voulais me
réinscrire dans cette histoire ça
s'appelle les exportés c'est-à-dire chez
Flammarion et vous l'aurez compris c'est
absolument passionnant et bouleversant
merci beaucoup Sonia de Villars vous
restez avec moi parce que c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris ce soir Jean-Rémy baudottes
France Info son histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée vous allez devoir il va nous
parler de la motion de censure de la
nupet a-t-elle été modifiée ou pas et
bien non on a enfin l'info il nous pas
tout la mise en garde du philosophe
pierre-ont Rita voyot sur les dangers
d'une vie politique judiciarisée à
l'excès et puis le regard sur la guerre
de Vincent et jeu ce soir Russie Ukraine
Dieu en relais de force bonsoir les
affranchis j'espère que vous êtes en
pleine forme on va commencer avec vous
Jean-Rémy le Briche politique je le
rappelle tous les matins sur France Info
il y avait un soupçon qui pesait sur
cette motion de la nupes contre le 49.3
sur le budget du gouvernement c'était
lundi dernier fin du soupçon vous avez
des informations à nous révéler alors ce
sont les informations de la rédaction et
du service politique de France Info et
la réponse est donc non des documents
annotés prouve que les mots immigration
immigrants n'ont jamais été dans le
texte contrairement aux accusations qui
pèsent sur la nuque la nuque qui est
donc accusée d'avoir caviardé sa motion
pour que le RN puisse la voter ça fait
deux jours que cette espèce d'info de
rumeur circule avant qu'on ait donc
finalement le fin mot de l'histoire ce
soir alors ça traduit quand même un
petit malaise pourquoi autant de
questions et de polémiques que ce
soupçon en fait a été lui-même un objet
politique d'où vient soupçon en fait il
a été largement relayé par certains
socialistes qui sont en guerre contre la
nuque des personnalités qui sont un peu
en congrès permanent comme
Jean-Christophe Kombat délice ravi de
pouvoir critiquer Olivier fort et la
stratégie du PS si cette rumeur a pris
c'est aussi que malgré les nombreux
démentis c'est que la France insoumise
sans prête à faire pas mal de compromis
pour faire tomber le gouvernement ce que
je dis là c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est
l'écologie c'est Yannick Jadot qui l'a
dit ce matin très concrètement sur
France Inter
on n'a pas Yannick Jadot alors quel est
le problème à gauche exactement mais que
quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est félicité
dans un tweet écrivant il manquait 50
voix pour éjecter le gouvernement
banalisant la porte des voies d'extrême
droite quand sur son blog le même
Jean-Luc Mélenchon mercredi revendiquer
un texte qui je cite ne comporte pas de
mentions répulsives pour récolter le
maximum de voix tout ça ça a créé un
doute le doute s'est installé la France
insoumise aurait-elle pu manœuvrer dans
le dos de ses partenaires c'est là où le
malaise s'est installé il était palpable
dans toute une partie de la gauche cette
affaire en fait elle met en lumière une
fois de plus les différences de ligne
parfois de pratique parfois même un peu
d'éthique politique au sein de la nuque
et cette fracture elle commence malgré
tout à se voir qui profite de cette
polémique à votre avis politiquement
c'est assez fascinant c'est un cas
d'école ce qui est intéressant c'est que
Marine Le Pen avait pris un peu tout le
monde de court lundi disons-le en votant
cette notion de la nuque aujourd'hui
cette petite rumeur elle a fait malgré
tout retomber le soufflet le principal
gagnant on a on aurait pu penser que
c'est finalement la macronie on se
souvient qu'hier soir Emmanuel Macron la
large utiliser c'est une polémique clé
en main c'est très facile à utiliser il
avait cette cette colère très préparée
contre le cynisme la nuque etc mais si
on sort deux secondes des Bizzbee
politique je me demande en fait quel
spectacle enfin c'est quand même
terrifiant qu'en pensent les Français
est-ce qu'ils comprennent seulement les
enjeux sous-jacents de ces alliances
est-ce que la poly la politique
ressemble grandit vous m'avez demandé si
on avait plus d'infos la seule info que
je peux vous dire c'est que non la
politique ne ressort pas grandi de cette
histoire merci pour ce parti pris genre
Rémi Pierre-Henri tavoyau bonsoir
bonsoir à vous vous avez envie de
revenir sur sur trois frères et sang qui
sont presque passés inaperçus dans cette
actualité parlementaire chargé oui
récemment le Conseil d'État a décidé de
condamner l'État français pour non
respect des normes de pollution et la
condamnation est importante c'est 20
millions d'euros ça c'est la première
information deuxième information
quelques jours après Édouard Philippe
ancien ministre Premier ministre passe
et convoqué par la Cour de justice
pour sa gestion dans l'affaire du
covid-19 alors il est pas mis en examen
à la sortie il sort comme témoin assisté
mais il a quand même été perquisitionné
son domicile et son bureau et Agnès
Buzin elle et Agnès Buzan également elle
fait un article dans le monde est dans
cet article elle dit elle qui est mise
en examen pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui dans le cas de la crise covid
elle dit bah c'est un juste parce que je
suis peut-être la première avoir dénoncé
la gravité de la situation alors
qu'est-ce que révèle cette actualité
grave confusion entre droit et politique
une grave confusion entre droits
politiques parce que c'est vrai que le
juge on peut considérer qu'il est
important pour vérifier l'honnêteté des
politiques pour vérifier que les actions
politiques soient dans les règles mais
évaluer une politique publique mais
ce substituer parfois parce que vous
voyez le Conseil d'État 20 millions
d'euros à qui va les donner aux
associations planningantes et aussi à
des organismes c'est lui qui va faire la
politique en quelque sorte et puis on
peut se demander si la Cour justice de
la République et ben elle est vraiment à
même de mesurer si par exemple la
décision de maintenir le premier
toujours des municipales c'était une
bonne décision ou pas qui le sait et en
quoi est-elle compétente
et en fait ça ça témoigne effectivement
d'une judiciarisation de la décision
périlleuse périlleuse pour trois raisons
première raison parce que la décision
politique c'est rarement une décision
entre un bon choix et un mauvais choix
mais en général entre un mauvais choix
et un choix encore pire donc le
politique est toujours un peu coupable
donc c'est oublie de la décision
politique me paraît périlleux
deuxièmement
on tend à substituer au juge le juge se
substitue en quelque sorte à aux
citoyens et parfois aussi au
parlementaire pour évaluer la politique
publique c'est pas son boulot et puis
enfin on peut se dire que avec ce cette
épée de Damoclès qui pèse sur la
décision politique on peut se dire que
finalement le politique va être
davantage amené à se couvrir qu'à agir
et ça c'est très périlleux alors on peut
répondre à ces dérives la première
réponse un peu radicale un premier
réponse un peu radicale supprimer la
Cour de Justice de la République voilà
ça dure
elle est née après l'affaire du son
contaminé sur une question très vous
souvenez toujours de cette expression
responsable mais pas coupable et bien
justement la Cour de justice la
République avait cette fonction de
déterminer ce qui était la
responsabilité politique est-ce que
c'était la culpabilité pénale éventuelle
bon pour ça qu'elle est composé à la
fois de juge et de parlementaire oui
parce qu'en fait les parlementaires sont
un peu mis sur la touche ensuite et les
parlementaires sont mis sur la touche et
donc elle devient une courge justice et
puis le deuxième point c'est peut-être
de faire en sorte que la reddition des
comptes soit mieux faite ça c'est un
gros travers de démocratie je pense que
le Parlement doit se saisir Mitterrand
disait méfiez-vous des juges ils ont tué
la monarchie ils pourraient tuer la
République voilà
merci je vais vous faire réagir Sonia de
Villers à la chronique de Vincent pour
terminer cette émission vous nous dites
que Dieu s'en est enrôlé de force dans
cette guerre de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine et oui on va s'arrêter ce soir
sur l'un des invariants de la russe le
recours au sacré
vous savez il était là tant au premières
heures de l'agression militaire il
devient aujourd'hui obsessionnel le
lexique du Kremlin est désormais truffé
de concepts religieux oubliés le
fantasme initial de la dénazification
place maintenant à la désathanisation de
l'Ukraine il faut terrasser je cite là
encore les forces du mal cette
martingale vient de loin la fleur est
déjà en 2014 à l'heure de l'annexion de
la Crimée plus près de nous à la mi-mars
lors du méga meeting du stade louzniki à
Moscou ce jour-là la lumière Poutine
arpente la scène avec l'entrain d'un
télévangéliste américain abreuvancer ses
fidèles en extase de référence biblique
et dans cette douteuse croisade il peut
évidemment miser sur le concours du
trésorthodoxe Kiril Patriarche de Moscou
et de toutes les Russes
pour le moins insolite et controversé
drôle de paroissiens en effet une
sommité spirituelle aux pulsions
furieusement temporel pour preuve son
train de vie fastueux et son immense
fortune adossait notamment au négoce du
tabac l'esprit étant mais la chair est
faible
comment tu écris et Cher d'ailleurs je
m'interroge encore il y a pire ce prêt
là qui bénit missile et canon qui promet
la rédemption au volontaire entre
guillemets comido fils pour le sacrifice
suprême il fut dans une vie antérieure
sous le nom de Mirail lov un compagnon
route voir un agent du KGB en Suisse
plus tard en 2015 on l'entendra prêcher
en faveur de la réhabilitation de Joseph
Staline pour un peu on oublierait que le
grand-père de Kyril pop orthodoxe lui
aussi fut déporté au goulag sous le
petit père des peuples qu'importe à
l'entendre l'accession de Poutine au
pouvoir procède d'un miracle divin on a
connu sound de latitude l'alliance du
sabre et du goupillon place au pacte de
la kalache et de l'encensoir bon et
keryl et est exploité aussi par par
d'autres pays il y a pas que la Russie
de Poutine il est surtout pas le seul à
puiser dans enregistre un loin sans faut
prenez le vassal du Kremlin le
Tchétchène ramzankadirov lui aussi
flétrit le satanisme occidental et
promet d'anéantir ses démons Ukrainiens
dans un monologue apocalyptique il vient
d'ailleurs de déclencher à la rencontre
le jihad dire que son père prénommé
armad animal qui président d'un temps la
république de Tchétchénie à l'oreille
siècle avant de rallier Moscou émis une
fatwa visant à légitimer la guerre 5
contre qui contre la Russie comme disait
Edgar force ce n'est pas la girouette
qui tourne c'est le vent notez au
passage que la propagande maison invoque
des valeurs traditionnelles patriotiques
familiale censée emporter l'adhésion des
chrétiens comme des musulmans va donc
pour le cuminisme belliciste et arrow
sur la perversion d'un Occident décadent
le mariage gay l'emprise du lobby LGBT
qu'elle prenne d'ailleurs la forme d'une
apologie sournoise du viol ou d'une
homophobie frénétique les allusions à la
sexualité sont au demeurant consub
potentiel à cette sacralisation de la
guerre Dieu pourvu qu'il en trouve
reconnaîtra les siens merci
Dieu dans la guerre
et ce patrimoine par Poutine mais c'est
vrai que ce retour en force du discours
religieux et du discours réactionnel
c'est-à-dire un peu partout en Europe de
l'Est je veux dire rappelons aussi la
Pologne rappelons aussi la Hongrie
indépendamment des problématiques de la
guerre qui se joue aujourd'hui autour de
Poutine et de ses affidés il y a aussi
la montée en puissance d'un clan
extrêmement conservateur profondément
anti-européen extrait en régression de
manière effarante sur les libertés
individuelles et extrêmement violent du
point de vue des mœurs que Vincent
rappelait mais voilà
ce retour de la guerre là on est en
Ukraine on parle de la moldav c'est pas
très très loin de la Roumanie j'imagine
que ça secoue aussi votre famille ça se
coupe pas simplement ma famille c'est à
dire que au moment de l'écriture de ce
livre on ne pensait pas chez Flammarion
pouvoir l'éditer sans une carte
aujourd'hui malheureusement par la
guerre fait rage en Ukraine la Roumanie
d'un seul coup c'est imprimé dans le
dans l'imaginaire collectif des Français
on sait la placer sur la carte la
Roumanie la mold la Moldavie et la
Transnistrie qui est donc seulement de
terre entre l'Ukraine et la Roumanie
merci beaucoup merci Sonia de Villers
d'être passé par la chaîne parlementaire
les exporter c'est-à-dire chez
Flammarion allez-y ça vaut ça vaut le
coup merci les affranchis la bonne
soirée documentaire qui commence
maintenant avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à
demain Manu même heure
[Musique]